envoie-moi déjà ton message envoie-moi
ton message vous avez vu cette histoire
elle achète un vase 3,99 € dans un
magasin d'occasion elle le revend 107000
dollars un collectionneur est-ce que
vous avez vu cette histoire c'est un
truc de fou regardez
ça c'est une histoire assez magique qui
se déroule aux États-Unis à quelques
jours de
Noël en se baladant dans une friperie
une jeune Américaine tombe sous le
charme de ce vase affiché au prix de 3
99 convaincu que l'objet a du potentiel
elle décide de l'acheter de faire
quelques recherches et de poster sa
trouvaille sur les réseaux sociaux très
vite elle apprend que son vase obtenu à
moins de 4 dollars est en réalité une
pièce d'exception créée par un célèbre
architecte italien mise en vente aux
enchères l'objet vient d'être vendu plus
de 107000 dollars permettant ainsi la
jeune Américaine de repartir avec un
sacré
pactol avec l'argent récolté cette
éleveuse de chevaux a annoncé vouloir
rénover sa
salut elle elle est super intelligente
parce qu'elle a vu qu'il y avait un M
dessiné sur le vase elle en a rien dit
et M ça lui a fait penser à Murano non
la ville ENF l'île à Venise on fabrique
des éléments en ver V oui exactement
c'est en face de Ven non enfin là elle
était aux États-Unis mais elle a vu que
ça venait de Murano et donc du coup elle
l'a acheté sans rien dire et la
plusvalue est incroyable quoi elle
pensait qu'elle pourrait le revendre
1000 dollars
100ar ça vaut 100000 qui peut donner
100000 un collectionneur
européen rest secr on avait parlé de
l'histoire du masque africain qui est un
peu le même système où vous savez un
brocanteur avait acheté de retraités un
masque en un lot de de produits qui
venaent d'Afrique et parmi ça il y avait
un masque qui venait du Togo je crois et
qui qui a acheté quelques dizaines
d'euros et qui était revendu 4 4,2
million d'euros non mais 4,2 million
d'euros une arnaque Jean-Michel 42
million et ça est la sentence vient de
tomber le tribunal a donné raison au
brocanteur et donc le couple a été été
il en fout complètement de ce que je
raconte on a décroché en fait Paron pas
j'ai vu j'ai vu j'ai vu j'accepte
dis-moi il y a combien de à
retraiter au début non non mais merci
Jean-Michel pour cette belle histoire
vraiment bravo non vraiment vous avez vu
qu'à béune il aura pas aura pas
d'illumination de Noël cette année Scand
pour des raisons écologiques je peux
plus les blérer moi je peux plus les
blérer dis jeux c'est insupportable non
mais quoi tu es content toi bien sûr
mais
s va derrière le
[Musique]
sapin derre sa der
der derrière le sapin je peux plus on
monte d' niveau
avec non mais regardez non mais sans
déconner on peut plus franchement j'en
peux plus non mais arrête tu faisais une
très bonne émission tais-i un peu
regardez R de bune l'esprit de Noël se
fait plus discret le maire Olivier gaker
dit non aux illuminations la décision
fait débat je suis allé à haras je suis
allé à lance et là-bas il y a des
décorations donc c'est quand même plus
jolie la mairie lutte contre la hausse
des prix de l'énergie moins de lumière
de Noël c'est ainsi 120000 € d'économisé
regarde c'est 120000 € et pour garder en
fait forcément tout ce qui était
chauffage dans les écoles en fait la
ville c'est comme une famille on a on a
des budgets et là justement on a on a
René sur
C vousz vu c'est pas pour des raisons
écologiques c'est parce que ils disent
que c'est un budget qui est trop 1200 €
et qu'il fallait choisir entre chauffer
les écoles ou illuminer la
ville
par V même le soir bien de faire des
économies tu traverses
villagrcomies nécess des symbol on Esser
Noël de toutes part j'en mettez des
paillettes dans nos VI illuminé toute
l'anné c'est vrai il y a franchement là
alors ils ont payé quelques artistes
graffeurs qui qui font des dessins sur
les vitrines pour essayer quand même que
ce soit un peu j'ai une question à vous
POS maiscoute me fais chier je t'ai pas
je t'ai pas dit ouice que je t'ai dit
oui puis-je vous poser une
question
non
allez poser question pr alors tu la
poses à eux tu la poses à eux on dev
question a dit un truc dingue là vous
avez dit un trucing vous préférez que
des écoliers se gent pendant tout
l'hiver pour qu'on met TR guirlandes de
Noë làbas mais les autres années il
faisent quoi les écoliers se mais
l'électricité ne flambait pas le prix
n'était pas délirant la commune de béune
qui est très bien dirigé c'est un ils
ont pas
deun c'est un de centre droit il y a
plus
d'argent les élèves il les mett dans la
rue il se prèent ça ch je sais pas moi
moi un jour savez ce qui m'est arrivé et
ben sans rigoler je m'étais déguisé en
sapin de Noël et Ben et Ben et ben la
guirlande m'a brûlé les fesses arrête ah
c'est une gulande électrique tuas fait
les boules avec quoi quoi tu as fait les
boules avec quoi j'en ai rajouté non non
mais je te jure c'est vrai je faisais un
c'est vrai que la part de r C'est vrai
que Noël c'est même dans les yeux des
enfants quoi c'est c'est c'est ça qui
est l'avantage c'est que tu as oublié
l'enfant que tu étais maintenant que tu
es grand tu enas plus rien à F en qu'
pas grand regarde-le il il lui reste à
mon av aux enfants tous les mes qui font
ça supprim les sapins ont oublié qu'il
étaient des enfantsand pas mettre pas
pendant un
mois mais pardonnez-moi mais nous on
juge de Paris demandz aux administrés à
betune s'ils sont d'accord avec ça non
ils sont pas
contents mais peut-être que les
administ regezle il peut même pas se
raser la
barbe il pas voilà on le voit bien il y
a plus d' que les impôts locaux
n'augmentent pas voilà merci bon les
gars non mais c'est chant il y a pas
bétude il y a plein de villes où c'est
chip il faut un minimum minimum
minidéologie ou de l'écologie vous
assassiné la magine Noël ça son dro B
bien g verd a ass signé beaucoup de
choses on va pas se mentir depu béune le
Mare il est pas fiste pardonnez-moi je
saisah donc to to Noë il y a pas
d'imination pour l'instant il y a le
sapin il y a rien dessus on verraè tu V
rien mettre dessus m c'est dessous cade
tu as que un sapin
ou vra sapin pas vra sapin non pour le
moment il y a rien
tout tu as pris un vrai sapin mais ça ça
sapin et à l'image de ton slip c'est
vachement écologiste un vrai sapin c'est
vachementc un arbre quel est votre
problème avec bravo g bravo faites ce
que je dis faites pas ce que je fais et
la magie de Noël
[Rires]
connard allez les chéri allez m'emmerdez
euh j'ai été plongé dans un com
artificiel pendant 48 he h euh
Gill non il y a Madonna qui s'est confié
sur son spéalisation
compliquée encore et là ça va mieux ça
va mieux elle est en train
de ça va mieux elle était un concert à
Blin où ça Brooklyn
elle est revenue sur son hospitalisation
Madonna moi je kiffe Madonna en plus ou
l'ancien grand
artiste
Brach
une analyse mais c'est au
cortiste tu ve faireoi
plus
grandti Reno
[Rires]
granditë
belleiture
franchementre l'été dernier vous ne
savez peut-être pas mais je suis tombé
gravement maladeé infection bactérienne
dans mon sang et j'ai failli mourir j'ai
été placé sous comin artificiel pendant
48 he il y a des personnes très
importantes dans cette salle ce soir
pour moi il y a une femme très
importante qui m'a traîné à l'hôpital je
ne me souviens même pas d'elle je me
suis évanouie sur le sol de ma salle de
bain et me suis réveillé en unité de
soins
intensive merci Chavane elle m'a sauvé
la
vie ma mère qui réagit à bune qu'est-ce
qu'elle dit l'adjointe au maire de béune
c'est mon ami sopri bricour elle peut
pas blirer Gill euh voilà elle a dit ça
elle peut pas BL RER non bah tu peux
venir vener tu veux que je l'appelle
pour qu'elle te le dise non non je
préfère pas non mais c'est une bonne
équipe municipale qu'est-ce t qu'est-ce
ton c'est toi je travaille béune ils
sont excusez-moi c'est un mer de redit
qu'est-ceon de l'UDI proche de borlau
c'est quelqu'un de très bien voilà il
ont fait quoi comme réalisation
dernièrement à la mairie
il dernitionous quelques truc quell sont
leurs dernières actions vasy ah le
chauffage dans les écoles ah ouais ah
c'est nouveau
pas quelles sont leurs dernières actions
alors la voirie vous pouvez regarder les
travaux sont faits partout arrête de
fout ils ont
mytho excusez-moi vous con excusez-moi
vous connaissez betéune les betunois
vous les connaissez d' connais un déjà
allez vérifier bah allez vérifier en
centr-eville il y a plus aucun pavé plus
aucune aspérité la voirie est refaite
les trottoirs on été refaites toutes les
écoles sont chauffé vous n'êtes pas
d'accord vous n'êtes pas de bétune
excusez-moi
quel rapport Madon avec béune en fait M
alors non ça été compliqué pour Madon
très compliqué une infection bactérienne
elle a perdu connaissance et elle dit
que la seule bonne nouvelle parce que
donc elle a elle a repris sa tournée qui
avait été annulée et elle a réuni après
ça elle s'est réveillé de son Comat et
elle a vu ses six enfants c'est-à-dire
moi j'ignorais qu'elle avait 6 enfants
elle a deux enfants biologiques quatre
enfants adoptés et jamais on ne voit de
phot absolument mais moi non plus et
jamais on ne voit de phot de donna avec
ses six enfants et là elle a plaisanté
en disant la bonne nouvelle c'est quand
j'ai ouvert lesux soin intensif il y
avait mes six enfants que je n'arrive
jamais à réunir et qu'il a été au pied
de de mon l c'est une grande
artiste que c'est une grande
artiste ch on va passer